you
hi everyone is Gerry here's another cool
endgame study this one by I guess we can
say fan favorite Frederic Lazar this was
composed in 1912 it's a study that's not
nearly as sophisticated as some of his
others that I've shared with you in this
playlist but still one I'm confident
you'll enjoy in this rook and pawn a
specific endgame it's white to move and
just to be clear the notation gives this
away white is headed in this direction I
encourage you to take this as a moment
to challenge yourself a little bit
improve your calculation spend some time
try to work this for now it's white to
move what is the best continuation okay
the solution well before I share the
solution let me first know that white
cannot win this that's the first
conclusion he needs to come to there's
no fancy me to give me there's no fancy
way to pick up the rook in fact before I
even look at trying to pick up the rook
if that is something you were
considering a more pressing issue issue
is what are you doing about this past
pawn that's a single step away from
Queenie
white cannot win so what's the what's
the trickier to draw this endgame here
is what does not work what does not work
move one rook c7 this is no good
why you need to anticipate a resource
that black has now this is the ideal
placement for the rook to position
himself behind the past pawn but the
issue with that is there is now rook h5
and after the King moves rook c5 could
see this show up in many games it's a
little interference idea in this case
we're seeing it with the rook maybe it's
some lines could be with the bishop or a
knight that intersection square c5 a
square that the pawn is supporting
this will allow black to win rook takes
rook pawn takes what are we doing here
move the king take the pawn whatever
black pushes through and goes on to win
so after rook here do we come over here
to give check and then play here well
that's not working either black goes on
still pushes is up a rook black will go
on to win so what's the trick
well the trick here is to first give
this check this makes all the difference
in the world now the black King has
three options h 5 h 4 f 3 however two of
the three h4 and h5 would interfere with
rook h5 that resource rook h5 into c5
just to put it on king h4 now we would
come over here now the pond will be
successfully hunted down in the
resulting position will be a drum okay
okay so therefore the king must go to f3
only at this point only after we have
forced the King to f3 do we play over to
c7 how does this factor in we're gonna
find out now when rook h5 is played we
go into d4 and now when the rook plays
to c5 we can capture that pawn
excuse me capture the rook rook takes
rook pawn takes rook and now the key
move King d3 are you seeing what's
happening here the King now that if he
is on f3 instead of G form he is taking
some squares away from the White King
Khan is controlling D for the King with
its last move is attacking c2 and it
must push otherwise King takes pawn and
it would be a drop and now well if you
do push and promote to the Queen that's
stalemate
all squares taken away from the white
king no legal moves here same story
if you promote to a rook and let's
consider the other two under promotions
a promotion to a knight will not work
either because of Kings c4 and there's
now not a good way for the knight to
safely defend the pawn d3 or b3
the night is just captured and lastly if
you promote to a bishop that will not
work either because of once more
King c4 bishop a3 to defend trying to
hang on to that mating material but that
could be forced off the board with now
d4 pawn takes King takes draw by
insufficient material a clever one here
just two moves deep but requires an
understanding of well he needs to really
understand the difference between the
two King positions maybe some of you
didn't realize that this was even a
resource at all you need to anticipate
that this is you know many endgame
studies you think to yourself well I can
never really apply that in one of my own
games this idea right here is super
applicable this happens quite often
these little interference tactics in an
endgame a rook and pawn and game or
really just any type of endgame as I was
mentioning you know the rook in this
game was going to c5 but you could see
any type of piece interfering on this
what this intersection Square c5 but
giving a check first
forcing King to f3 and only at this
point coming over to c7 because with the
King a little bit closer he is helping
to have this stalemate resource
on board so a neat little one only five
moves deep but one I think I hope at
least you enjoyed feel free to leave any
feedback as usual in the comment section
below and I look at you in the next one
that's all for now take care
you
[Music]